it would appear that a move is being
made right now to suppress or even get
Rumble banned at the beginning is that
advertisers are pulling off of Rumble
because Rumble refuses to shut down
Russell Brand now most of you are aware
if you if you track the show over the
past week UK Parliament actually sent
letters to various social media networks
and television networks effectively
demanding that Russell Russell Brand's
deals be yanked or his content get
pulled now we are seeing big Brands like
Burger King and hellofresh pull their
ads off of Rumble sparking calls for
another boycott and I gotta be honest
I've been boycotting Burger King for a
long time and it's not political it's
just that their food is trash so you
know there's that